welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and with
Mindhunters season 2 reintroducing the
world to some of its most fascinating
serial killers I thought I'd break down
some of the real life stories behind the
show's most infamous names throughout
this video I'll be breaking down the
true cases of four of season 2's most
high profile names and discussing how
the show handled their on-screen
depictions in this video I'll be
primarily covering the Son of Sam the
Atlanta child murders Charles Manson and
BTK make sure you drop a comment below
if you'd like me to cover the other
serial killers of the season in a future
video as everyone featured in this
season definitely deserves their own
documentary if you haven't seen the
finale of season 2 of mindhunter and
aren't aware of the resolution of the
cases then I highly recommend that you
turn off now as there will be some
spoilers with that out the way I just
want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video now let's get into
my breakdown of the real life killers of
Mind Hunter season 2 The Son of Sam is
one of the first killers that we come
into contact with in season 2 of Mind
Hunter and the show depicts him as a
remorseless shooter that manipulated
psychiatrists and other industry experts
into believing that he had a degree of
insanity Holden called him out on his
Fabrications and this leads to a more
truthful conversation that allows for
some fascinating insights in real life
the son of Sam's real name was David
Berkowitz and the serial killer operated
in New York City during the years of
1976 and 1977. Berkowitz Was a Serial
shooter that randomly ran up to parked
cars and shot the passengers he
notoriously preyed on women with long
dark hair and this is paid lip service
too in the show during the interview
when it's noted that women completely
changed their hairstyles out of fear for
the killer Berkowitz taunted the press
and gave himself the Monica Son of Sam
claiming that he killed to appease his
father's insatiable craving for blood
throughout his Reign Berkowitz killed
six people and wounded seven and was
caught when his car was given a ticket
at a scene where he later attempted to
carry out a shooting after his victim
got away she reported the incident and
police were able to track Berkowitz back
to the parking fine upon being arrested
Berkowitz was apparently smiling and
bragging about how long it took for
police to catch him later Berkowitz
admitted that his reasonings were made
up and denied ever being possessed Holt
mcelany who plays special agent Bill
tension the show has tried several times
to interview Berkowitz but said the
serial killer does not wish to go over
the crimes anymore and now refers to
himself as the son of Hope Berkowitz is
now 66 and is currently serving six life
sentences for his crimes next up is the
Outlander Child Murders The Outlander
child murders are the main thrust of
season 2 and become the focus of
Holden's ongoing investigations
throughout the crimes similar to the
show were carried out by Wayne Williams
though he was only ever convicted for
two of the deaths and there are several
theories that there were other
perpetrators that were involved the
murders themselves took place between
1977 to 1981 and they involved the
deaths of 28 children and adults similar
to how how the show depicts his capture
Williams was caught by a bridge
surveillance team who stopped his car
after they heard a large Splash after
Williams failed three polygraph tests he
became the number one suspect though he
taunted the police and even held a press
conference at his own home after fibers
were found that linked Williams to some
of the abductions he was arrested and
convicted though he still maintains his
innocence alleging that the crimes were
carried out by the KKK and that this was
a cover-up to avoid a race war whether
he will ever find out if this is the
truth or not is still a known but
Williams is currently 61 and serving a
life sentence and now unto Charles
Manson Charles Manson is arguably the
most infamous killer that appears in
season 2 and his on-screen portrayal
doesn't disappoint either Manson was
born November 12 1934 and had a very
troubled childhood and during his teens
committed several offenses that meant a
lot of his life was spent in
incarceration during the late 60s after
being discharged from prison he began to
form a cult that later became known as
the Manson family acting under
instruction from Manson The Family
committed several crimes including a
failed assassination attempt on then
President Gerald Ford they later went on
to commit the tape murders which
involved the deaths of several people
including the then wife of Roman
Polanski Sharon Tate who at the time was
eight months pregnant the Manson family
went into the home and killed her and
five others upon exiting the house they
wrote the word Pig in Blood on the wall
this was because Manson wanted to frame
the Black Panthers to create a race war
known as Helter Skelter however after
the killers were caught this quickly
dissembled Manson spent the rest of his
life in jail where due to his Persona
and interviews gained somewhat Celebrity
Status Manson died on November 19th at
the age of 83 and though he's gone it's
fair to say that his life is still a
point of Fascination it really can't be
overstated how much Damon Harryman Nails
Charles Manson and after his betrayal of
the man in Once Upon a Time in Hollywood
the actor looks like he's carving out a
reputation for playing the man going
forward mind Hunter perfectly captures
his message and Charisma and makes for a
dramatic betrayal that shows just how
controlling the man could be and finally
is BTK which stands for bind torture
kill BTK is hinted at throughout both
mind Hunter season 1 and 2 and it's
clear that the show is building up to
his eventual takedown which will no
doubt happen in future iterations of the
show BTK remained at large for over 30
years and operated between the years of
1974 and 1991. in 2004 he was finally
caught after sending letters to the
police as well as a floppy disk which
was traced back to his local Church's
computer BTK was revealed to be Dennis
Rader a seemingly innocuous man that had
an extremely Dark Side to him Raider
killed over 10 people in his life but
seemingly stopped which is very rare for
serial killers those close to him later
stated that radar could be seen spending
hours upon hours looking over old books
and shoeboxes in his Treehouse and
psychologists assumed that he had found
a way to relive the fantasies without
carrying out the ax them
radar is currently serving 175 years in
prison due to the 10 consecutive counts
of murder that he was charged for due to
the time scales of mindhunter I imagine
that the show will eventually have a
time Jump and we will travel forward
from the late 70s and early 80s to show
his capture in the 2000s either way BTK
is a fascinating killer and Raiders
sheer normality on the outside showcases
just how unassuming serial killers can
be mind Hunter completely Nails this and
it's accredited to the show just how
accurate each killer is obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on the
killers and if you enjoyed this video
then please give it a thumbs up and make
sure you check out my breakdown of
Mindhunters season 2 which will be
linked at the end I discuss all of the
ins and outs of the seasons and give my
thoughts on where the show could go down
the line if you want to come talk to me
about movies TV shows games and comic
books then you can follow me on Twitter
at definition YT it's the best way to
get in touch with me and is the perfect
place to suggest new videos and content
I also just want to let you know that
we're giving away a free copy of John
Wick 3 on Blu-ray and all you have to do
to begin with a chance of winning is to
like this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on Mindhunters season 2 in the
comments section below the winner will
be chosen at random on September the
10th and the Blu-ray will be shipped out
from then to ever gets the prize so best
of luck to everyone who takes part
this is a channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
thank you
[Music]